tenemos
caos en el lugar del accidente los
equipos de emergencia acudieron a ayudar
a los heridos las autoridades investigan
las causas de como el camión que
transportaba más de 100 migrantes por el
estado de chiapas se volcó matando a
decenas pues afortunadamente la
respuesta de todas las instituciones con
roja protección civil bomberos fue muy
rápida la verdad es que las personas
y
los migrantes en su mayoría de américa
central y buena más rotados en el camión
las autoridades dijeron que el conductor
que huyó del lugar del accidente iba a
toda velocidad el perdió el control en
la avenida que conecta a la ciudad de
chiapa de corzo con la capital del
estado tuxtla gutiérrez
las personas que veníamos dentro y en la
vuelta
puede tener la fuerza de las personas
del peso
pues no sabíamos por ella
el presidente atrás manuel lópez obrador
expresó sus condolencias
lamento profundamente la tragedia
ocasionada por la volcadura de un
tráiler en chiapas que transportaba a
migrantes centroamericanos es muy
doloroso abrazo a los familiares de las
víctimas para los migrantes que huyen de
la violencia y la pobreza
chiapas que está en la frontera con
guatemala es uno de los sitios de mayor
tránsito con el objetivo de llegar a los
eeuu
muchos de ellos pagan a los
contrabandistas que esperan por toda la
frontera entre guatemala y méxico antes
de que ellos se dirijan a la frontera
norte
otros migrantes han optado por las
caravanas donde hacen el trayecto a pie
son vulnerables a los cárteles de las
drogas y al clima extremo la cantidad de
migrantes indocumentados ha aumentado
desde que joe biden llegó a la
presidencia muchos de ellos esperan que
cumpla su promesa de eliminar las duras
políticas de su predecesor donald trump